[Music]
I have
hey everyone we'll get back to you
regularly scheduled programming and by
that I just mean this show uh in a few
minutes wanted to let you know that uh
Thursday December 15th is going to be
our last Regular Show of the year and
then Monday December 19th will be a
Christmas special where we do some of
the Crowder gifts back we found some
families in need and if you're looking
for something political it's not then
it's just supposed to be uh you know
something to enjoy Before Christmas
where we uh we do what we can here with
your support from uh from mug club uh to
help those in need and if you know
someone around uh you're not the woods
right now just to do what you can you
know give what you can whether it's your
time whether it's your resources there's
some people who need some help this time
of year and it's a great time to do it
it's a great time to start that habit
and thank you so much that's why we're
able to do it here at mug club which
also brings me to something else this
Thursday we will be making some major
announcements big news uh good news
regarding Mud Club and its developments
as we go into the new year some big
changes changes we're excited about and
uh yeah changes of course that uh that
you have made possible
and you know obviously hopefully all
hopefully all great news
right Blaze so we'll announce that on
Thursday December 15th our last show
before the Christmas special on Monday
December 19th enjoy the show
[Music]
this is nice yeah we don't do this
enough I know we should do this all the
time remember God it's just nice to get
out of the house
[Music]
no no no no no we're just here
geez this happens all the time I know I
know non-stop probably because someone
had to show up in full skeleton makeup
that's not fair you guys used to do the
same thing yeah 120 years ago it was a
fashion thing back then it was different
people were doing the skeleton look yeah
700 A.D called they want you to uh get a
new thing
hey guys what do you think about doing
etching cloaks
yeah I can make patches see how we like
them let's make sure it's not a
three-piece rocker I don't know anyone's
thinking we're in a gang no that won't
help at all freaking crusaders had to
ruin that one for the rest of us oh that
ship sailed a while ago hey nope Don't
Panic we're we're just here to get so
you can't you can't talk with these
people get used to it new normals here
guys maybe for you
what does that mean yeah what does that
mean here we go all I'm saying at a
certain point what you get isn't worth
what you do okay come on yeah we all had
to make changes not this [ __ ] again look
forget about it forget I said anything
you don't think it's because we have
hell following with us do you
here
doesn't help
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
glad to be with you as I just was then
but now I have headphones on yeah
that's the difference that's how you
know it's a cold open versus not is the
headphones in chat I uh hear you out
there just to you know simmer down we'll
be talking about this Thursday
that's YouTube comment that's not the
same as chat the speaker's not on it no
okay I'm getting a weird echo my
headphones glad to be with you it is one
of those days
I don't have I don't have a hot shower
it's not possible it's now going on
three four days at my house and I have a
shower here in the office for emergency
that also the water heater does not work
I should have hot shower money you
should that's all I want is it water
what is it people say the tankless well
anyway I don't want to get into it but
it's been cold showers for seven days
but you know what I don't know we'll see
if that actually helps when people swear
by it okay a lot to get to today
a lot of you may not be able to you know
sort of parse the uh the Twitter dumps
that have been taking place there's one
on Friday obviously after our last show
and then there was another one just
yesterday I believe they called them
Twitter dumps three and four
we're going to give you the ins and outs
everything you need to know of course
all the references are available at
lightworthcredit.com but specifically
contrasting how they apply their rules
how they did apply their rules for many
many years to one political group versus
the other you don't live in a free
country if you have a country with laws
it's whether the laws are applied
equally and of course as we've discussed
big Tech far more powerful than
government at this point this is what
Libertarians could not plan for as seen
by the fact that a few people in the
back room got rid of a sitting president
so we'll talk about that Elon Musk has
called out fauci uh he's also discussed
uh um you know Prosecuting fauci which
people say social media isn't real life
well it is if it brings criminal charges
and we'll also get into some predictions
that we made last week that have come
true because that's always fun all right
you can comment below as to what you
think is most pertinent from the Twitter
files before we get into it pause it if
you're watching the archive and then
come back to it and then see if we match
up Gerald a how are you sir I'm doing
well getting over a little sickness
you're not over the sickness you're
still sick I should do some Voice work
right now yeah yeah strike with Aaron's
hot kind of stuff yeah that's what I
would call your voice a hot Iron
Monkey pox yep that's not hey that went
away yeah right next emergency
just not engage in unprotected sodomy
with strangers at a Norwegian tech music
festival well that seems easy enough
well how will I live that worked how are
you other than not I'm okay hot water
again I just I just really wish I had
some hot water my plan continues to work
it is definitely Carol's fault
I don't know what happened first water
heater went out then the second and
they're like you know just give me one
of those tankless water heaters well I
recommend it you said wait I'm sorry you
can have unending hot I never I had
never heard of it before like yeah but
now I've still never used it
successfully and you know him you love
him fastest man on his feet you can
follow him on the Twitter Mr Dave Landau
how are you sir Ahoy I'm not bad how
about you I'm fine did you have you been
have you read all the Twitter files I've
looked through some of them I've now
read them no of course you haven't even
it took me a very long time to go
through it and it's awful yeah it's
really something and fauci great guy yes
great guy the Twitter files all right
Pride swallowing speech yes they will
never fully tell you about it it's
horrifying name that movie then but you
know what No One's Gonna perk you right
up what's that this this first clip that
we hit so before we get into anything
else uh this is a it's a short clip but
you know we just want to feel good
because it's Christmas
it's the season yeah for Yuletide Joy
yes especially if it involves a reindeer
let's watch I begin to pass out I know
what you're thinking please tell me this
ends the way it does then my head hit
the wall oh yeah
I know oh poor girl I have a general
rule with nature don't get near it don't
try and screw with it and even if they
even if they decide to take it upon
themselves and by that I mean any
animals in God's kingdom to approach me
the answer is still no
the horns aren't to help guide it Fly
exactly this is a lady who would say
trust the science do you see those
calcium calcium deposits on its head you
know why those exist they should hurt
you yeah yeah exactly but I saw a Pixar
film yeah
just watch it one more time yeah one
more time watch this Disney princess
let's see how it is
Ginger down can you see with all the
voices of a mountain
[Laughter]
paint with all the uh
like of your Hemorrhage yes I hope she's
all right yes
by that I mean I hope she learned her
lesson so out there just don't I'm not
even comfortable around petting Zeus No
I don't I don't like anything like that
I only want domesticated animals yes
exactly that's it have you been to uh
park Safari it's where you would drive
through that I think they have them in
the States you drive through the zoo and
they would come up to your car that's a
bad idea my brother was bitten by a
zebra we'd have taken to the emergency
room yes I saw the Great Outdoors with
John Candy where the Bears get all over
the car that's all I need to do yeah
exactly I don't want to go near these
places wonderful rubber butt on that
bear that's true all right the bear it's
part the bear that was Bart the famous
grizzly bear okay
who won the bear attacked the news
anchor did you see that one it's one of
my favorite Clips ever there was a bear
at a Dairy Queen drive-through grizzly
bear I think in Wyoming that just took
their stuff what you get whatever you
want yeah a bear I know yeah it's a free
pass yeah it is have you ever watched
bears fight guys I'm sure we can watch
this on muggler if you watch bears fight
they have zero cardio yeah they're like
they fight for about 30 seconds and then
one is actually holding a tree like
and the other pair doesn't attack him
because he's just equally out of shape
yeah but these are animals that will eat
a beehive yes
like that's knowing full well it's going
to hurt like hell yeah I feel rumbly in
my timely time for something sweet
you're dead the inside of your stomach
is Macaulay Culkin's casket and my girl
congratulations Pooh Bear okay
Elon uh Elon Musk this is a great one
we're going to get into the Twitter
files but uh Sunday he teased um what
was going to be release of the Twitter
files
and this is just a gym he uh tweeted out
Elon Musk my pronouns are prosecute
slash fauci
well that was fast oh we have uh we have
square bear on overlay side come on
bring that up collage A3 bring it bring
it up Square bear come on Roger Dodger
huh collage A3 ah it just went away
there you go
look he was teasing the audience
and uh then uh someone asked him uh will
this be explained in the new Twitter
files part and Elon simply replied uh
yes
and then he explained fauci lied to
Congress and funded gain of function
research that killed millions of people
not awesome IMO which of course stands
for in my opinion for people who are not
familiar with the nomenclature
we are good job I like that I appreciate
that explanation we speak Twitter Jack
I thought it said for I might observe
and this is one this is one of those
things where people will say I'm just
tired I just shut off the social media I
just you know just shut off the news
just go live your life and I understand
that you do need to unplug sometimes but
here's the deal when people say Twitter
social media isn't real life of course
if you're just talking about some
Anonymous egg saying I'll kick your ass
that's not real life right however you
don't just get to shut it off if these
people are colluding to remove sitting
presidents to change uh not only public
perception but perhaps let me be very
careful here the procedures regarding
voting in defiance of their state
constitutions if these people are
committing crimes guess what that's
still the real world I don't care if you
committed the crime via snail mail
telegram carrier pigeon or Twitter
it's a crime so people out there say
just want to shut it off I get that it's
exhausting guess what life is exhausting
life is struggle you have to fight back
every single day it's a battle of inches
until the end what else would you do
roll over and die I'm sorry that it's
annoying I'm sorry you live in a time
where the fight is hard don't roll over
and die yeah and by the way what they
want you to do is to shut it off just
long enough for them to have their way
exactly right they just want you to pay
attention to other stuff just long
enough yes that's all they need well
they want a Burger King yeah they want
you to leave it on while they kill
millions of people yes
hold the pickles hold the lettuce
election theft kind of upsets us yes
have it your way
voucher King it's okay because within a
limerick you two what are you gonna do
is you're gonna take that seriously
now
I'm in a mood you are I was at a
conversation with a very expensive
lawyer as to oh don't say this we know
what I'm going to say so remember these
were all points by the way we're talking
about fauci that uh Rand Paul Dr Rand
Paul made before Congress and if the
Twitter files as they continue to be
released are verified meaning if our
intelligence agencies actually give a
crap you know as opposed to like the
hunter Biden laptop where the FBI just
ignored it when they rated uh when they
rated giuliani's house
um
fauci actually with Rand Paul lied about
it on the record that's a crime in
Congress regarding exactly this here's a
refresher even the NIH now admits that
Eco Health Alliance did perform
experiments in Wuhan that created
viruses not found in nature that
actually did gain in lethality seven
with all due respect I disagree with so
many of the things that you've said
these little held the Lions took the
virus
15 and combined it with wiv one and
caused a recombinant virus that doesn't
exist in nature and it made my sicker
mice that had humanized cells you're
saying that that's not gain of function
research according to the framework and
guidelines so what you're doing is
defining a way gain of function You're
simply saying it doesn't exist because
you change the definition on the Nia's
website preponderance of evidence now
points towards this coming from the lab
and what you've done is change the
definition on your website to try to
cover your ass basically
that's completely incorrect I have no
way you say we continue to support
research at the Wuhan Institute of
virology you approved it in August of
last year I have a great deal of respect
for this body of the Senate and it makes
me very uncomfortable to have to say
something but he is egregiously
incorrect In what he says they're
wearing two masks history we'll figure
that out on its own hey I don't give a
[ __ ] if you have respect for that how
about respect for the American people
you need to start everyone here needs to
start rethinking the way you look at
government they are your employees
all of them all of them you pay their
salary unfortunately anywhere else where
you have employees right they have a
duty to you if you pay their if you pay
their salary or of course they have a
duty to the customers if the customers
obviously purchase goods or services
which ultimately leads to paying their
salaries you pay for them you pay their
salaries but instead they answer to
special interests instead they answered
a big pharmaceutical companies as we saw
the MRNA vaccine instead they uh answer
to International lobbyists who have no
interest in American sovereignty you pay
their salaries but they don't answer to
you I respect this body we don't respect
your body we don't respect your frail
little five foot two body
they cannot even throw a baseball no he
can't whatever it is
think about that there's nowhere else
you pay their salary but you they have
no accountability as it relates to you
yeah that is by the way wasn't even
elected wasn't even elected and you pay
a salary here's something else that's
relevant as these Twitter files
keep coming on down the pike uh the
Pfizer CEO I want to make sure I get his
name right Albert borla by the way
announced uh he was stepping down along
with what he thought about the MRNA
vaccines I was surprised when they
suggested to me that this is the way to
go and I questioned it and I asked them
to justify how can you say something
like that but they came in they were
very very convinced that this is the
right way to go they failed that the two
years that of war on mRNA since 2018
together with biotech to develop a flu
vaccine made them believe that the
technology is mature and we are at the
cost of uh television a brother
so they convinced me I I followed my
insect that they know what they're
saying they're very good
we need to find some clips of that guy
out there touting it before yeah like
this is great we know it works and now
he's like they convinced me because I am
stupid yes I was simply what you call
scared yes so I agreed I agreed I did
not ask for receipts yes very tiny man
scared the crap out of me yes yes that's
true and without you but it was not
because of tiny men but because of big
black men he hid next to him look like
Suge Knight on steroids he says to me
say what again
and I not say anything he asked me if
they speak English in what I was talking
to translator not make sense very scary
by the way you know you can't take these
people seriously when everybody on
Twitter that hates Elon Musk now for
some odd reason he's showing people the
truth and they hate him for it is saying
oh you're inciting people to violence
against the lgbtq aaip plus Community
because you have your pronouns like this
you're making fun of this and he is just
he he has no shits left to give not my
language he's just absolutely over all
of this he's like wokism has to die his
tweets right now are incredible yeah
they're on fire he is absolutely and
he's doing the right thing he is going
right into the teeth of it well here
it's a perfect contrast to that uh
what's his name borla yeah perfect
contrast to borla who had to come out
and do the bidding right of the MRNA
with Pfizer now he's saying hey uh I I
was wrong or I was misled is what he's
saying
um
he had access to information and he was
uncomfortable he had to come out and lie
anyway Elon Musk has access to
information he's only released some of
it he knows what he has in these Twitter
files and he's very emboldened that's
what you need to watch for hey hold on a
second what information does he have
that we don't have and why does he feel
so bold I can guess by the way hit the
like button if you're pretty happy about
seeing these developments uh and if you
would like to see fauci obviously
prosecuted because hey you know what uh
guess what uh the algorithms say we're
dead here on YouTube and by the way it's
a it's a Morning Show Monday through
Thursday 10 a.m Eastern you can watch it
here on Rumble nothing will make me
happier than you heading on over to
rumble right now okay I also think
though real quick with Elon he's
releasing a little bit at a time because
you don't want anything to get lost yeah
I mean he does just have to put out
because there's going to be a lot well
not only that but that man right there
Andrew Breitbart who was the first
person who ever posted any of my content
to any um right-leaning websites he
started that and did it with Acorn he
did it with Anthony Weiner because he
gave the media the opportunity to do
what they do and accuse him of lying and
he let them walk right into a trap that
is what Elon is doing right now yeah
that's what happened if you don't
remember I'll talk about it again uh
Anthony Weiner he had prepared a press
conference to come out and say that
Andrew Breitbart was lying and someone
had had fabricated a story and it was
untrue and this was the right wing Echo
chamber until Andrew Breitbart took that
Podium like a boss and said I have the
pictures and I didn't release him for
the sake of his family clear my name
Anthony Weiner had to change his speech
to an apology that's why you hold back a
little bit of information which brings
me to my next segment actually before we
get into the Twitter files which will be
a little bit nerdy so last week we
discussed Brittany Greiner right is that
story broke in real time we also
discussed Kanye West and Milo Nick
Fuentes what was going on right there
and made some predictions which brings
us to a new segment called called it
well good Lord
[Music]
now look
I don't say this to toot our horn here
right someone tried to correct me and
say was tout your own horn the other day
tout why would you town a horn I don't
need to touts no it already works you
just have the horn you toot it I have a
horn and all I do is toot it yes exactly
you don't even have a car no I you know
the horn didn't work right I was trying
to tout it and I got in an accident yes
I was also trying to tout while texting
and driving I'm not a woman I can't
multitask yeah you can't do that so uh
this is just to toot our own horn it's
uh when we make predict we don't make
predictions a lot on this show just so
you know it's by the time you see a
prediction that we make it's been
filtered through as Gerald often says I
would like to comfortably bet far more
than a dollar yes it's like Elon Musk
with the Twitter files where there's
some information that I often might have
access to that maybe you don't that I
can't reveal at that moment in time you
watch we're not in that business of like
like uh Newt Gingrich or Frank Luntz
where they make or Dick Morris where
he's always wrong so we do make a couple
and last week it's almost shocking so
this brings us to the Griner story okay
I don't know if you remember this but
this happened Thursday to refresh your
memory
Biden decided to bring home uh
americating Brittany Greiner in exchange
for the merchant o'death instead of the
Marine Paul Whelan which they have
discussed now on Russian television this
is just to set up the story real quick
Billy
foreign
thank you that's my favorite one but one
two three is Russian
did you learn that Japanese into it I
did not no is one two three is ichini
sun in Russia it's just one two three
that sounds very similar
because after three you die yes no one's
ever there is no foreign
on Thursday Dave wasn't here but we
called it on Thursday and we actually
called it as a joke where I kind of gave
you my read on the situation as far as
how the Russians would react and some of
you were upset because you thought I was
saying this but I wasn't saying this I
was saying that this is what the
Russians would say this was last
Thursday on this show then we'll get you
exactly what they're saying today
Thursday it's
Audi Crown Prince and the UAE
well we're trying to make the United
States look really stupid you want to
play along how do I do that
just release the WNBA player wait you
mean a lesbian with death those who's
addicted to manage right right right
it's going to make them look really
stupid and guess what you're gonna get
out of War
craft
good good oh man I was having a bad
weekend my pants and uh
oh but this is mad boy never interrupt
your enemy when he's making mistake ah
okay I should send the I should send the
former Vice President Biden to Tiff
Street sir it's a good idea I'll send
the paperwork is very Skype yeah yeah
that's what happened laughing at you and
really the prediction was maybe because
of all the resources that you provide
and support with Mud Club so this is
really more so you you nailed it because
I like it
here's what they that was kind of a joke
but not really here's what the Russia
Today editor-in-chief uh Margarita
simonyan Simone neon however I said
Margarita Margarita you wouldn't expect
that for a Russian name I have no idea
Daiquiri simonyan had to say only a
couple hours later the very same day
it's not our transcript she said this is
foreign
the point is that you missed it I was
saying that's what the Russians would
say because Joe Biden former Vice
President Joe Biden was saying she's the
best among us if that is our ambassador
think about it you know who our
ambassador our ambassadors were during
World War II and by the way wasn't just
white guys
Joe Lewis
yeah Jesse Owens just to give you an
example these were the people we said
these are the best Among Us here in the
United States I'm not talking about we
obviously took a while to get the full
civil rights don't mistake what I'm
saying what I'm saying is do reefer
addicts yes what if you have to look
look at the best that America has to
offer
our Representatives the people who are
paid by your tax dollars you pay their
salary said Brittany Greiner is the best
Among Us when there's a marine sitting
there who's not being who's not being uh
would it be extracted
and they are laughing at
us and by the way that was not just some
random person on RT that was the
editor-in-chief of course of RT it was
making that point for us yes exactly and
uh this brings us to it so you can
comment below the economy is pretty bad
right now and what are we going to do
without the WNBA yes exactly that's true
we need the money well we need the
write-off there's still a thing right
yes it's more of a deduction really yeah
so the government can say we have no
profit this year look how much we dumped
into we the WNBA is the sinkhole yeah I
mean they should have to the men should
have to split their listen as long as
you're going to stand side by side with
the WNBA and say they should be a league
just as much okay here's the deal you
have to play with the same terms as
women's soccer and men's soccer you have
to split your salaries with them let's
see how much of a league you think they
should be when it costs you money well
NBA players LeBron James name me a WNBA
player who's not Brittany grinder
comment below go no time's up you lose
so here it brings us to another one you
could have given them two hours I hate
that I know why I could have said well
take your answers on mug Club
oh I'll be playing hate symbol or not on
monk Club this brings us to another and
some people were upset now again
understand that when we make these
predictions means we're fairly confident
so yeah this is another one that we
called last week and you helped us make
this call last week remember the episode
on Kanye where I said that uh Kanye West
or yay was being used and Milo
specifically was using yay to
potentially my my read in the situation
with the dinner and this is how fast
move news moves it was the entire news
cycle last Monday yeah and Tuesday and
now you forget about it why because we
find out that what we were presented
wasn't exactly true and isn't as
damaging to uh president Trump as we had
hoped it would be but I said last week
did I say I said we we I'm saying I was
speaking from the perspective of media
we hoped it would be meaning media so
they said we better move on
um I told you then that it really likely
wasn't a story that was significant
because people like Milo uh and other
people who were at that dinner were
using yay to make Trump look bad that
was the prediction Kanye West did he
know or did he not know but I think it
would be pretty clear as to Milo
yiannopoulos's motives going to
Mar-A-Lago and goading Kanye West at
this point Kanye West is being I believe
used as a pawn again and you guys
shouldn't be championing it because he
says a couple of things that you like so
Kanye West uh has brought in someone
like like Milo and someone like Nick
Fuentes now the motivations there do
matter if you're a conservative
right let's say you like Donald Trump
let's say you like Ron DeSantis
it doesn't really matter because these
people
I would argue want to destroy all of it
they don't want the conservative
movement they don't want Republicans to
do well they certainly don't want Trump
to do well there is a personal Vendetta
against Donald Trump with these
individuals so he brought these
individuals to Mar-A-Lago which was not
vetted by uh Donald Trump which I think
was foolish yeah I don't think you
should let anyone in there and sit down
with with them for dinner if their goal
was to was to actually uh basically
inflict damage on Donald Trump well then
it's been incredibly effective because
it's been a media cycle now for three
days a lot of you were mad because you
maybe liked some things that Kanye had
to say and by the way these are two
separate issues here's where we you
nailed it
[Music]
three hours lady three hours later NBC
uh they used
they didn't use that same point they
just they spoke with Miley Annapolis and
this Milo said that's what he did he
said quote that he set up the dinner
just to make Trump's life miserable
because he knew he would mishandle it
um and uh he said that he wanted to show
him that the the people who put him in
office the kind of behavior from Trump
meaning would come back to bite him so
he set it up quote just to make Trump's
life miserable Kanye West yay was used
he was used we talked just because he
liked some of the things that he says
and he's going he's going up against the
grain and I respect that you know your
enemies the woke people you still can't
Overlook the fact that he's being
exploited by people and I will tell you
that happens in this movement all the
time we need to do better and you all
and we all need to do better in calling
it out when we see it because someone
like Kanye West probably further down
the trail could be an educated
individual
but when you see someone being used you
got to help them yeah here's another one
that we called here last week regarding
Kanye West
um yay sorry the dead naming I just you
guys
Kanye West if I think if I say yeah you
wouldn't really know no I don't I don't
go feel like is he celebrating it just
sounds like it's dead naming either you
know of course yeah thanks for
clarifying I think his birth certificate
says I don't know what it says probably
Lyle yeah sure it's Franklin so here we
were in that same episode mentioning
that uh Kanye West was being used by
people in his Circle at that very moment
that was the call so here's the thing
Kanye West was was wronged he was used
here's the thing he's being used now so
there are a couple different theories as
to what's been going and this is just
some of this is going to be speculation
hopefully I can present a case to you as
to why and here's where all of you
helped us nail it
[Music]
I really didn't like that right after
that tobacco
Milo hit yay with 116
000 bill for three days of work uh as
campaign manager which led to him being
fired now here's the deal I don't I
don't know if yay wanted to make Trump
look back which also
that's one hell of a rate wait what does
that include
and then and then you'll have someone
like Milo go out and complain about
grifters yeah oh when people when they
make it their entire branding to
complain there are some grifters out
there some grifters who do need there
are some people who are exploiting
people out there who need to be me
someone like this charging 116 000 bill
for three days of work and by the way I
don't know that that Kanye West knew
that Milo and Nick Fuentes wanted to
just make Trump look bad he might have
gone in there with with uh altruistic
genuine intent just to be clear so it
still proves the point he was being used
by people who saw an opportunity he
needs your prayers he needs your help
he doesn't need your cheers as other
people try and run him into the ground
and uh you know squeeze him for every
last penny we need to do better yeah hit
the like button if you if you kind of
see that because we've got a lot of
flack people saying you should you
should support him I was like no no he
wants to support right now you're not
supporting him right now you're putting
money in the pockets and control into
these handlers you don't want a Britney
Spears situation no and when it's
obvious like that and it was very
obvious what was going on here right
Milo's past and his comments about
Donald Trump were out there for people
to have seen like he did not like Donald
Trump he said he was going to get his
revenge on him for not taking care of
him for all the work that he did and
then for him and a guy like nikuentes to
end up on that kind of ticket so to
speak you knew what was going on and so
just saying hey don't support them
that's 100 right go a step further have
the balls like we did to go no no no no
no this is somebody being used right now
I'm not just gonna not say okay I won't
support this I'm gonna say stop using
people because this is obviously what's
going on here you have to call it out
every single time yeah well you know you
recognize it when it's happened with you
you yeah that's what happens when you
recognize it when people look it's the
story as old as time you reach some
level of success you have people who try
and get their claws in and I really do
hope that uh that yay does uh better for
himself but yeah I would think think
that counts as using him using him to
try and make Trump look bad and then
charging him 116 000 that's quite a bill
it is yeah it's what what did you do for
me well I made everyone think you're a
Nazi yeah yeah that will be 116 clams
yes
yeah I know I gotta calculate the tip
huh someone get me in ethnicity that I
can't say
Jew but you said it did you see that
when he said one time he was on Lex free
music I can't say the ethnicity though I
know I'm not supposed to say it
he's a Jew
it took him about two seconds nobody
even asked a follow-up like he didn't
have to say it all right
it's five dollars for every time you
said something bad about the Jews yeah
filing for bankruptcy yes and this is
the thing if you if the handlers get to
say hey it's the it's the Jews right you
don't see that they're using you now
that's just that's the problem it's them
it's them out there using you and by the
way I'm not saying that Kanye West has
never been abused by someone who happens
to be Jewish we can't discount that
I'm sure that's happened I'm sure he's
also been taking advantage of by people
who aren't Jewish but you have people
around him saying it's the Jews it's the
Jews it's the Jews 116 000 it's the Jews
it's the Jews let's use him to make
Donald Trump look bad it's the Jews it's
the Jews that's where you don't don't
drink all that Kool-Aid yeah and we make
all the references available at
credit.com so that's important as we go
into something which could be nerdy
could be tough to digest so we're going
to try and simplify this for you give
you everything you know give everything
you need to know right now I'm speaking
too quickly I'll breathe
so over the weekend we had the newest
batches of the Twitter files yes yes of
the Twitter files released by
journalists Matt taibi and Michael
foreign
I should have talked about this on the
show on Thursday it fell between the
seats I didn't see it I'm sorry
name that movie line so uh the files uh
they showed us how Twitter Executives
led by the quote head of trust and
safety a guy named Joel Roth who by the
way will do a full Deep dive onto this
guy tomorrow because there's a lot more
there just on Joel Roth yeah um and how
they applied their rules to Shadow ban
accounts okay so here's what we want to
do we want to go through this to give an
example of how they applied the rules
with conservatives versus uh leftists
because a lot of conservatives out there
have complained
now it's confirmed and this is what the
left will do is they paint themselves as
this is so important the dynamic they go
we're victims why because we're trans
we're victims why because we're black
we're victims why because we're women
then they throttle everyone and then
they blame the actual victim going hold
on a second hold on a second wait
I'm not being allowed to speak freely oh
what are you a snowflake they're trying
to are you triggered no no we're not
triggered we're just supporting Freedom
across the board including for you to be
an [ __ ]
which are succeeding at wonderfully with
big Tech it's only gone one way before
you get into voting before you get into
machines
it's enough what happened with big Tech
is enough to affect not only the outcome
of this election every election
thereafter unless something is done
about it and now we have the receipts
we've had our own receipts for our own
channels for our own platforms but now
you have it across the board so let's
give you an example of how it was
applied to conservatives or is it here
am I right you're right there you go my
right your left upstage downstage I have
a theater I know some of the theater
terminology okay so that's uh let's go
through what happened with uh
conservatives so uh Twitter uh labeled
this tweet by Donald Trump as misleading
his tweet was big problems and
discrepancies with mail-in ballots all
over the USA must have final total on
November 3rd
I love how he writes like shorthand as
he would with his employees hey we
really need to must have final total
no three
no three
so
Joel Roth who we just discussed uh
decided that they should Mark the tweet
meaning label this tweet as misleading
or misinformation
but didn't even know on what grounds and
this is what is important they're
looking for a way to apply a rule to
conservatives yeah even when they don't
have it and when they have it clear as
day in front of them they don't apply it
to people on the left you will see this
we will give you more examples so this
is Joel Roth saying thank you I agree
with the recommendation meaning labeling
this tweet bring it up there Square bear
flagging right now with leadership given
its president of the United States can
we use a new Doc per public interest
interstatial for review and here's what
a Twitter executive said about labeling
this tweet hey very well done on speed
folks what this is all designed for and
a huge win for the platform oh boy wow
basically we have a bias and we want to
do something is there any policy that we
have that we could possibly come up with
that makes it make sense yeah no just
following the policies nope and by the
way for someone to win that means
someone has to lose yeah correct who
loses it's not Donald Trump huge win for
the platform it's a loss for you yeah
they win you lose
that's the issue here
it can only win if you if you lose and
by you I mean the American people I mean
not just conservatives I mean anyone who
isn't full on left Palo Alto Silicon
Valley
lgbtqaaip Abomination that whole thing
you all lose that's their win let's
compare this to something that's a
direct Apples to Apples
for leftists on Twitter other yeah yeah
there we go
I'm always because I'm looking at the
monitors reverse I know right from left
and some people are still going to say
this no you're this is my right it's
your it's your left
so this was a tweet from a former Ag and
photo negative of Ned Flanders Eric
Holder and it was labeled
it was labeled at first but then the
label was removed by Joel Roth I believe
labeled can you guys let me know make
sure I want to make the get this right
misinformation misleading information
because I don't want to be fact checked
on that and get it wrong some of them
are misinformation some other labeled
misleading information this was labeled
initially then they changed it this was
his tweet it's too late to use the males
given the Supreme Court rulings I urge
everyone to now vote in person early
Vote or use drop boxes this is Eric
Holder protect your health but don't let
the court and the deliberately crippled
Postal Service deprive you of your most
precious civil right he said that
Donald Trump again for comparison said
big problems and discrepancies with
mail-in ballots
he said Eric Holder deliberately
crippled Postal Service we say that here
on YouTube we've been removed suspended
for Less that's applying intent Donald
Trump just said this isn't working yeah
too many discrepancies we have to have
this count he was saying deliberately
crippled remember that's what they were
trying to tell you before the election
just like they were trying to tell you
that there wouldn't be a vaccine before
the election and not to trust it that
they wouldn't take it former Vice
President Joe Biden Kamala Harris before
the election don't trust a vaccine if it
comes out during Donald Trump now they
take credit for it this is a direct
Apples to Apples comparison
and then it was labeled then they pulled
it back for Eric Holder here's what Roth
said uh regarding the tweet
everything in it is factually accurate
[Laughter]
here's the thing I agree
I agree
so did President Donald Trump
you're not free if you live in a country
with laws
whether the law is applied equally if
the IRS can select people's lives to
destroy based on political persuasion
guess what you're no longer a free
country that's how every single corrupt
government gets a foothold now we have a
few Tech oligarchs who are more powerful
than the government sitting president
slapping with everything we've got exact
same statement everything in it is
factually accurate said Twitter yeah
well and everybody that's come out and
supported these guys too we talked about
this a minute ago they were creating
their own policies they're saying well
they're trying in real time to figure
out the best way to handle this
information and just enforce the
company's policies and you guys are
coming down no that's direct bias
they're just trying to make sure that
Donald Trump is silenced his tweets
flagged means they're not going to show
up in people's feeds as often they're
not going to show up promoted they're
not going to be pushed out to the public
like they would otherwise and so most
people won't get to see that information
right right that's all you need you
don't need to actually ban somebody from
Twitter you don't need to actually kick
somebody's tweet off so nobody can see
it anymore you just need to make them
think that yes my information is getting
because who could possibly have imagined
that Donald Trump took a liking to
Twitter
yeah right so they were trying in real
time to take down a sitting president
yes
excuses they did hey you know I'll just
use the language so that YouTube doesn't
suspend me or Twitter I'll use Eric
holder's language they deliberately took
down a sitting president Oh weird they
deliberately crippled
a sitting president's amplification and
reach to the American people who elected
him ridiculous
spot boy is he skilled okay welcome back
and hit the like button right now if you
can share leave a comment because guess
what this doesn't mean anything on you
to the algorithm says that we're dead
check in uh of course you get the rubble
button if you're watching speaking of
limited uh well hold on a second James
was about to say no but like regardless
of really what your political stance are
stopping a sitting president from
speaking to their people is one of the
most immoral things I've ever heard of
has anyone here said that former Vice
President Joe Biden or president Kamala
Harris needs to be removed never once
never once and by the way we'll get to
that later on I mean his brain has but
other than that nobody here right I
don't care if he mashes the keyboard no
leave it up for all to see what I said
YouTube and I said speaking of limited
reach yeah exactly yeah being being
flagged and being banned and being
Shadow whatever the term we're just not
monetized okay all right fine and then
if you're not monetized people won't see
the content uh okay and if people search
your name they'll just find people
attacking you and people trying to rebut
your segments but not find your original
segments you can type in the name of
this show the title and not find it and
by the way this application wasn't just
limited to Donald Trump again if it's a
win for Twitter you lose which is why
they also targeted other conservatives
so let's give you another example with a
conservative
I got the hand right this time nice job
so hard with a reversing image hey you
got it though where should we mail the
award so we got it right once
this is a tweet from uh Square bro
what's the name of this Georgia
representative
uh this is
looks to be representative Jody Heiss
Jody Heiss okay I wanted to make sure I
had that right so uh representative Jody
Heise it's a guy
was slapped with a label and the label
on this tweet oh was male voting mail-in
voting is safe okay this is what this
representative tweeted out say no to Big
Tech censorship mailed ballots are more
prone to fraud than in-person voting
that shouldn't be controversial it's
just common sense geez Twitter slapped
it with a quote mail-in voting is safe
if it's so safe then why of most of the
countries in Europe not allowed it with
the with very few exceptions and the
same thing in the United States there's
a process where you have to request it
if you need a mail-in vote absentee if
if mail-in voting is sick then everyone
will just do mail-in voting all the time
they would have always been doing that
before the pandemic there was a reason
that they didn't what's that reason
again this is not about what's true it's
about what is politically expedient and
they were working overtime to try and
affect this election it would all be
done online if it couldn't be
manipulated yeah of course and look if
they were looking for an opportunity to
prove this point right or wrong they
would have just done some research that
we brought up on mail-in voting saying
fraud does not have to exist for mail-in
voting to be very very fraught with
problems people not getting it done on
time people things getting lost in the
mail which is exactly what Eric Holder
was saying the mail is crippled so
therefore it's not going to get there on
time and your vote won't be counted but
here's what you have to do all you have
to do is go to a heavily r or D leaning
place and either over count that and say
yes we're going to take this in the mail
or just oops trash oops trash oops trash
I know this is a heavy Republican area I
don't want Donald Trump to win all I
have to do is throw these things in the
trash on accident I got lost in the mail
not to mention the incompetence I have
the next day shipped now for two weeks
three can openers and one has yet to
arrive Bezos
or whoever else you might be yeah he's a
liar
why did I pay for next station it's like
299 if you want to get it same day great
sorry it's been delayed were you gonna
refund me yeah how about just get it to
me I still don't have a can opener
really yes I do not I should just go and
buy a can opener okay no can opener no
no are you I've been eating a Swiss army
knife I swear to God I've been eating my
Swiss army knife can opener every day
and every time I feed Joe loose I've got
to give him the pumpkin can or the sweet
potato candy look at it I just get mad
and I throw something in the kitchen
like where's my candle I've ordered
three we'll bring you a can opener too
I've had the same issue with a
double-sided uh can opener
seems they're running short on that no
but everything I've ordered that doesn't
come on time it's like well it's coming
from China it's like well it still says
Prime two days yes so that it should be
two days I made sure my can opener was
made in the states I know I want I want
American-made can openers I've always
said that you know me yes
it is homemade Tommy Union crap correct
Dave those days uh identify as weeks I
apologize yeah three days is really too
yes sir so the point is take the can
opener times three orders still haven't
received it only uh you know that's your
vote for the leader of the Free World
yes its pronouns are weeks months yes
rain
or snow means uh we will not be there
sunshine either Sun yes it's too hot
really weather is not our thing yes we
like a very light natural Cloud canopy a
little Breezy otherwise otherwise my
hair frizzes yeah it does
so Roth decided to apply a soft
intervention to avoid by the way what
was really just an Optics backlash where
again this representative said mail in
voting
is more prone to fraud so Roth decided
at Twitter this is behind the scenes
said I think going too far down the
rabbit hole of labeling critical speech
I.E critical of our handling of this
case is dangerous it becomes a
self-reinforcing Wawa censorship cycle
so they just gave it a soft label saying
mail-in voting is perfect
it was not controversial it was a true
statement this is like we had to change
my mind when I said you know anytime
that governments have limited speech it
is ultimately led us down the path or
LED these countries down the path to
eliminating people's personal freedoms
he said do you have a source and then I
said okay well we can go through Mao was
China we can go through Russia we can go
through Nazi Germany Venezuela and do
you have a source I'm like Cuba and I
keep going against do you have a source
do you have a source are you are you
claiming that I need to have a source
which we provide usually publicly here
references to tell you that limiting
freedom of speech can lead to the
erosion of Rights and then he said that
he supported it and I said okay name me
one place it's worked
I don't even need a source name me one
and he couldn't give you an answer
this is what they always do so right
here they just say melon budding's great
where's your substantiation they don't
have to provide any mRNA vaccine is
tested well now the former CEO of Pfizer
who stepped down said uh no
no
yeah but if they're not allowed to sit
at the table then they never have to
provide you with any transparency or
references so let's compare that
treatment of the Georgia representative
two
a leftist this is an another direct
Apples to Apples comparison this is um
Rick G grossner
this man describes himself as having the
third highest IQ in the world oh really
if you describe yourself like that
you're a [ __ ] yes yeah that's the truth
how else am I gonna pick up the ladies
yes I have the third house
you know what a lady's gonna say who's
two and one
[ __ ] oh
yeah yeah I don't know how you lose
[Laughter]
uh his tweet wasn't labeled at all this
is a tweet from the third highest IQ in
the world you mustn't be afraid to dream
a little bigger Rosner I hope it's
misspelled he said that check with your
local USPS folks to see how slow the
mail is also find out when mail-in
ballots arrive in your state but mostly
vote ASAP Trump and his new Supreme
Court will try to steal our vote so our
numbers have to be huge now according to
the Twitter Executives that tweet in
contrast to the Georgia representative
who said mail-in voting is more likely
to be more likely to be prone to fraud
Twitter Executives with this one said
that it was understandable here's a
quote Ah that's understandable believe
that it's a reference to the United
States Supreme Court decision on
processing mail-in ballots that arrive
after election day
there's a lot to read in these Twitter
files what I wanted to do is pull out
direct Apples to Apples comparisons so
you can see when a conservative says it
versus when a liberal says it they have
not been applied these rules equally
they are entirely arbitrary everything
is opaque and it's by Design and so when
you see the left screeching when you see
them Furious right now about the changes
that Elon Musk is making when you see
the people walk from Twitter behind the
scenes they are walking because they are
no longer allowed to apply these rules
in a completely unequal fashion that's
what they've been used to
so by the way here's another example I
think that's pretty important here and
you can go and read the whole files I
mean there are hundreds and hundreds of
pages
if you read all of them when Twitter
decided to ban president Trump the
suspension uh declared after close
review of recent tweets from the real
Donald Trump account and the context
around them specifically how they are
being received and interpreted on and
off Twitter we have permanently
suspended the account due to the risk of
quote further incitement
to violence now
keep in mind
that this was the Tweet do we have the
the tweet from Donald Trump yeah let me
read this right here that caused this
shitstorm
incitement to violence
go home with love and in peace remember
this day forever he said that's the
ending but he said these are the things
and events that happen when it's these
are the things sorry you won't know if I
don't know these are the things and
events that happen when a sacred
Landslide election Victory is so
unceremoniously and viciously Stripped
Away from great Patriots who have been
badly and unfairly treated for so long
which we now know of course badly and
unfairly treated you see it right now go
home with love and peace like the alien
from The Simpsons Mr Burns
remember this day forever go home with
love and peace Twitter removed his
account for quote further incitement of
violence
he's quoting Stalin
[Laughter]
one example now here's the thing you can
say there's an interpretation because he
was saying the election was stolen which
by the way you've seen from Hillary
Clinton you've seen from Amy Klobuchar
this is something that has been said by
people on the left boast
both preemptively and after the 2016
election election right that was stolen
by the Russians so if you want to
consider that an in segment to violence
okay I don't think you have a leg to
stand on find me one example Twitter one
example one of Donald Trump calling
anyone to violence go
because we can show you exactly where he
called people to peace go home and love
and peace remember this day forever you
may not like that he said the election
was stolen you may not like that he said
mail and voting is more prone to fraud
you liked it when people on the left
said it find me one example ever of
Donald Trump calling people to violence
throughout his presidency and don't do
the standby with the proud boys thing
which again is something taken out of
context don't do the very fine people on
both sides because he said I'm not
talking about neo-nazis who should be
condemned totally we've shown you that
clip Ad nauseam I'm not going to show it
to you today find me one example that is
as clear as go home and love and peace
find me the take to the streets
in Rage and War
find me the equivalent to Kamala Harris
discussing the rioters they're not going
to stop and they shouldn't stop
find me the equivalent from Donald Trump
if you're going to say incitement to
violence that is
the yang
to things go home in love and peace
that's why the man was removed yeah the
then sitting president
I can't believe that that was their
justification for this again looking for
a reason to get rid of somebody and then
hoping that your policies come up with a
way to make it happen yeah right that's
all it was well and one person says this
guy is going to steal the election and
the other one says we're worried that
there could be some tampering with
mail-in and the one that you take it
away from is the set is the latter it
just doesn't make any sense to me
whatsoever well it also broke by the way
with Twitter's policy their own policy
in several ways so let me give you an
example Twitter said that it didn't
attempt to determine quote political
interpretations of tweets that's what
they said that was their policy oh
that's a lie yeah they interpreted go
home and love and peace as oh he's
telling people to go get their mortars
you know Riot yes love and peace mostly
peaceful riots mostly love mostly two
billion dollars in Damages peaceful rats
they also completely disregarded their
public interest exceptions rule that
stit hears again all the references will
be made available at live cutter.com
Link in the description I highly
recommend you read all of this because
we will never have enough time to get
through all of it this is their public
interest exceptions rule it says at
present we limit exceptions to one
critical type of public interest content
tweets from elected and government
officials given the significant public
interest in knowing and being able to
discuss their actions and statements
another employee by the way
let's talk about this on an internal
slack Channel which is why we don't use
Slack
slack yeah which they're like ah we can
hack this like what if I take a picture
of my computer screen
I forgot Snapchat I forgot about the
picture phones
what's really sad is it took uh uh a
fairly moderate richest man in the world
for any of this information to even come
out yes exactly otherwise you wouldn't
even know
so Joel Roth by the way was responding
to an employee on the internal select
Channel we'll talk about him tomorrow uh
this is what he said about Trump's
account in this specific case we are
changing our public interest approach
for his account to say any violation
would result in suspension we aren't
completely getting rid of the public
interest approach again we're not
getting rid of it just in this specific
case we are changing our public interest
approach to say that there was a
violation and the violation was what
incitement to violence the tweet that
resulted in incitement to violence go
home and love and peace do you live in a
free country
do you live in a country with free and
fair elections if these people said we
are going to remove the sitting we are
going to remove this man
we are going to throttle his Tweets
we're going to label them we're going to
eliminate the amplification people won't
be able to retweet people won't be able
to share leading into an election
and by the way before you try and do the
whole both sides [ __ ]
this is something important which kind
of shocked us yeah because we know that
there are Rhino wieners out there I'm
not a republican I'm a conservative I
don't do the whole oh Centrist no no I'm
a conservative I'm not necessarily a
republican because I know a lot of
Republicans and I don't like them that
being said this is important to note
taibi he wrote examining the entire
enforcement slack Channel we didn't see
one reference to moderation requests
from the Trump campaign the Trump White
House or Republicans in general we
looked they may exist we were told that
they do
however they were they were absent here
so think about that for a second the
fascist is the guy
who is saying go home and love and peace
and saying hey we need more transparency
in our elections keep it this guy was
the president of the United States
there wasn't a single request
to remove or even censor or throttle
envious political opposition so it's not
just what you see what does that tell
you it tells you two things people on
the right we actually believe what we
say we believe we don't want censorship
we don't want people being removed and
it tells you
that Donald Trump just like us this is
why we say fine we don't care if we're
monetized we just want an equal playing
field when it's an equal playing field
the ideas win
your bet the best case scenario for
Donald Trump was no one to be removed
and for people to be able to do what
we're doing right now contrasting the
left and the right and coming to the
truth that's what it tells you the
confidence
is what matters there because they know
that their ideas stand on their own the
left has no cut now you see with this
Administration whether it's Spotify
whether it's Twitter whether it's
Facebook they require the elimination of
voices of opposition we talk about
Arizona
Katie Hopps just didn't debate
Kerry Lake
one person says let's debate and by the
way this isn't some Anonymous Twitter
person I get it you can't debate
everybody Mike Tyson doesn't beat the
gold it doesn't fight the Golden Gloves
runner-up from Missouri I understand
that these are two people neck and neck
running for governor of Arizona Kerry
Lake Katie Hopps one's the Secretary of
State who determines the protocols for
the election no debate
I don't want to give a platform to let's
just call it hate
Donald Trump was itching to debate that
guy lived for it never once said silence
political opposition
the left do it all the time not one
example that is very telling when people
say both sides are the same they are not
the same they are not even remote just
remember everything that was being said
about Donald Trump that was factually
inaccurate too if anybody had a claim to
say Hey you have to take this kind of
stuff down because that's not true play
the play the rewind the tape 12 seconds
15 seconds you see I'm saying not
neo-nazis and yet every single Newsroom
in the world is running find people on
both sides that I'm supporting white
supremacists right he had every Russia
collusion right spying on his campaign
he had every right to reach out to these
companies and say hey take this stuff
down right right the election every
right to take this stuff down and he did
none of it yeah think about that where
he says go home and love in peace yeah
and they go
this is a HP this is insight into
violence removed yeah it's so badly too
that they want to prevent more of it
right exactly they want to prevent more
of it meanwhile no one
from that camp no one from that white
house as far as we know and certainly
not to the same degree but right now not
one I know you're thinking hey some no
none
not one request during that point wow
they were being beaten while they were
being kicked in the nuts
that tells you something pretty
important it's the same reason that we
do things like change my Minds it's the
same reason that we provide all
references we believe in more
transparency We Believe sunlight is the
best disinfectant the left believes that
you can't handle speech that may be
challenging to you so let's just label
it all hate speech Let's just label
everything that we
foreign
oh what is that it's a beer do we have
to be through this again Tim geez
you said you were stopping you weren't
gonna drink anymore I know I'm sorry I
forgot to brush my teeth this morning
and I just didn't want to have like the
morning so you decided to wash it out
with beer yes
wow and it has I haven't followed the
logic yeah it's well it's so-called
alcoholics yes that's called alcoholism
if you actually want to brush your teeth
now you can use this they've been a
sponsor of the show you know spry gum
spray yeah have you used it I haven't is
it awesome let me throw you throw my way
oh wait hold on the pack just got it all
right got it gonna just I have another
one right here magic uh if you guys
think you know spry is a gum out there I
think actually what's her name Dr Rhonda
Patrick talked about it on on Joe Rogan
uh they use Xylitol it's a just go to
spry you can go check it out is it
spry.com you can buy it on Amazon you
can go and see the actual benefits
clinical trials regarding chewing with
uh spry gum uh poor oral hygiene by the
way is like links to things like
diabetes oral cancer Alzheimer's chewing
this gum it just it actually I have
never had a cavity in my adult life and
I had a small one because of my wisdom
teeth right they were like that's gonna
grow yeah this is totally anecdotal but
you can actually check the peer-reviewed
research on their website it's never
grown the dentist it's like I've never
seen anything how how is this not grown
and I'm like I don't know but I said
could it be this and he said it could be
big Dental they're lying I think my
dentist is a drunk as well I think it's
my dad your dentist is Casey yes yeah
chewing between brushing this is
actually uh stuff it's a it's fantastic
stuff they're a wonderful sponsor to the
show I use it they do the same thing
with clear nasal spray yeah Salah told
them go in on YouTube and type in Dr
Rhonda I think Patrick on Joe Rogan she
just talked about Xylitol gum and the
benefits they're in and anytime there's
something that can help you
hate that is actually proven by science
not thus science but science I recommend
it uh but uh Yakuza you we really need
to solve the severe problem with
alcoholism hit the like and share button
if uh and let me know comment below if
there's some info that you think we
should get into a little bit more from
the Twitter files or you think that we
missed something
but we're going to fix Casey's
alcoholism and by that I mean fire him
right yeah right and then play hate
symbol or not on mug Club thank you
Rumble YouTube piss off
oh
foreign
[Music]